-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
You're watching at home.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you very much.
We're very excited here, guys.
Christmas is only 11 days away.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, last week, you went,
"How much for shipping?"
And now it's like,
"$59.99 and my first born?
Let's do this. Okay."
[ Laughter ]
Get this --I saw a new survey
that said New Yorkers'
least-favorite Christmas food
is peppermint bark.
[ Laughter ]
I like peppermint bark.
I do.
I especially like
how the chocolate soothes
the open wounds caused
by the shards of candy cane.
[Gravelly voice]
"Merry Christmas."
[Normal voice]
The survey also found
the most popular
Christmas food is...
-Ritz crackers.
-Ritz crackers? No.
[ Laughter ]
That's not Christmas food.
Ritz crackers?
I mean, it's a food, sure.
It's like...
Pigs in a blanket.
[ Audience oohs ]
Jesus was like, "Thanks for
keeping my birthday classy.
Appreciate it."
Pigs in a blanket.
Apparently on Christmas,
people ask themselves,
"What would Jesus'
brother-in-law Randy do?"
I read that right now --
I love --
By the way,
I love pigs in a blanket.
-I'm all for it.
-I'm all for it, man.
I read that right now
the cost of ingredients
for popular holiday desserts
is surging.
Thankfully, every family
has that same blue tin
of Danish butter cookies
that's been floating around
for 20 years.
"We didn't finish these yet?
How come no one's eating
these square ones
with no sugar on them?"
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this.
According to a poll,
one-third of Americans
start buying holiday gifts
two months in advance.
That's risky 'cause a lot
can happen in two months.
It's like, "Here's that Kanye
sweatshirt you wanted."
You go, "Hey. Wait. Hold on."
[ Audience ohhs ]
"Put it in the box."
♪♪
Speaking of presents,
this year,
75% of people said they plan to
buy gifts from small businesses.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
Small businesses.
When they heard that,
Santa's elves were like,
"One more short joke,
and I'm gonna cut somebody!"
And you go, "No, no.
It's not a shor--
Small businesses."
75% of people want to shop
at small businesses,
which explains this ad I saw.
-Oh, really?
-This holiday season, support
your local mom-and-pop shop --
Amazon!
We know what you're thinking.
How does a "family business"
have 800,000 employees?
Easy. We're all cousins.
That's not a warehouse.
That's a family reunion.
Get back to work, family.
Amazon. Help! We're tiny!
-Yeah. Aww. Mom-and-pop.
[ Applause ]
Well, let's get to some news.
President Biden has reportedly
vented to allies
over how much the media
talks about his age.
And at one point he even said,
"You think I don't know
how F'ing old I am?"
[ Laughter ]
This is a real thing. Yeah.
His staff was like,
"Of course you do,
but just to be safe,
toss out a number."
[ Laughter ]
"Higher."
Yeah. Biden was furious.
It only got worse
when his chief of staff said,
"Well, he hasn't had
his nap today, so..."
Biden was upset. He cursed.
He ran up to his bedroom,
slammed the door,
cranked up Bing Crosby.
"You don't know me!"
[ Laughter ]
Some more political news.
Since announcing his 2024 run,
former President Trump
has been relatively quiet,
but today he said that he's
planning a major announcement
and posted this video.
This is real.
We didn't make this.
Take a look.
[ Dramatic music swells ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Jimmy:
"Major announcement."
[ Laughter ]
"Major..."
-God.
-Is he announcing Dean Cain
as his running mate?
I don't know what he's --
I think the major announcement
is that Trump
has a lot of time on his hands.
Okay.
Right after that was released,
Ron DeSantis' poll numbers
shot up another 20 points.
Can we see that picture again?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my goodness.
Let's be real.
If Trump tore his shirt open,
we'd probably see
five layers of Spanx.
You know?
[ Laughter ]
Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Switching gears, apparently
the IRS has been contacting
OnlyFans creators as part
of a criminal tax investigation.
-Ooh.
The IRS actually said they're
sending two agents at a time --
one to do the investigation
and the other to make sure
that the first guy
is actually doing
the investigation.
[ Laughter ]
Get this.
Mark Zuckerberg is spending
so much time and money
on the Metaverse
that employees are worried
that he's going to
destroy the company.
Well, here to clear things up,
live, via satellite,
is Mark Zuckerberg. Mark?
-Hey, Jimmy. Don't mind me.
Just gonna be chilling
in the Metaverse
while we do this interview.
-Okay, sure.
Mark, these are pretty serious
allegations from your employees.
How do you respond to them?
-What you're hearing in
the press is really overblown.
We're investing a lot
in the Metaverse, sure,
but don't worry.
I'm giving it my full attention.
[ Club whacks ball ]
Ugh! Sliced it!
-But your -- But your company
lost $80 billion worth
of stock value.
Do you have any ideas
on how to fix this?
-Trust me, Jimmy. $80 billion
is a drop in the bucket.
We'll gain it all right back.
Cinnamon! Cinnamon, notice me!
Notice me! Cinnamon!
-"Cinnamon, notice..."
-What?!
-I think that's
all the time we have.
Mark Zuckerberg, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay. Take care, Jimmy.
-Alright...
Alright.
Guys, I heard
that the CEO of Taco Bell says
gen Z wants to eat chicken
instead of beef.
[ Cheers ]
Then they added,
"But it doesn't affect us
'cause what we serve
is technically neither."
[ Laughter ]
You're all clear.
Don't worry about it.
Whatever you want. It's both.
That's how I remember.
I had the lasagna. Yeah.
Some more business news.
Costco is planning
to raise the price
of their annual membership.
-Ooh.
-[ Audience boos ]
-Yeah, Costco is
getting more expensive,
and you can tell
they're a little fancier now.
Watch this ad I saw.
-Welcome to ze new Costco.
Ze home of elegance.
A seven-pound bucket of Nutella.
Sophistication.
Turtlenecks and batteries
on the same aisle.
And class.
Old people eating hot dogs.
Costco. Like Walmart
with a doorman.
-That's...
That's interesting, I thought.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Costco."
-You guys --
Have you guys seen this?
The newest trend being
brought back in style
is the lower-back tattoo.
[ Audience groans ]
As we speak, a bunch
of 40-year-old guys are like,
"Maybe a calf tattoo of Calvin
peeing isn't far behind?"
Yep, lower-back tattoos
are back.
Well, now I think we know what
Trump's big announcement is.
Yeah.
"Check out my Trump stamp."
[ Applause ]
Finally, we have
exactly three shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time
for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for "12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters."
Here we go.
-♪ 12 days of
Christmas sweaters ♪
♪ Three days left ♪
-That's right. Every show
between now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a bodacious Christmas sweater
from the
Countdown to Christmas Cabinet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right!
And since -- since
there are three shows left,
let's open door number 3.
[ Drum roll ]
-Ooh!
♪♪
-Wow. Thank you very much.
-Yes. Of course.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. Can we dim the lights
a little bit?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hm. Beautiful. Alright.
Now let's see who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone look
at your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get
a drum roll, please?
[ Drum roll ]
3-0-2!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on down! Hey!
♪♪
Hello! Ha!
Hello. How you doing?
Nice to see you.
What is your name?
-Jackie.
-Jackie, where are you from?
-Long Island.
-Long Island!
I love Long Island!
I love Long Island.
I know it gets a little chilly
out on Long Island.
You'll have a beautiful sweater.
-Thank you.
-But it's missing --
It has a couple
of beautiful holes in it.
I think you'll need this
in Long Island.
And you'll just fit right in.
No one will even know
you're wearing it.
-No one will even know.
-Would you like to try it on
right now for everybody?
-Absolutely.
-Oh, this is going to be fun.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here you go.
There's no right way to put it
on. I gotta be honest.
Well, you've got your arms
in the sleeve. That's a win.
♪♪
Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my gosh. Look at you.
Look at this. You look gorgeous.
Look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You look beautiful! Oh, my gosh.
Is that not fantastic?
Happy holidays.
Nice to see you.
Thank you for coming
to the show. You look great.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
You can go up to your seat.
Thank you very much.
-Thank you so much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's the best.
♪♪
Can we get a camera shot
of her going --
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh, my God.
You don't even know
it's happening.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, you look great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well done.
-Whoo!
You know what?
I'm in the giving spirit. I am.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I really am.
Why does just one person
get a gift?
Why can't everyone
in the audience get a gift?
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right!
It's time for "Tonight Show"
Stocking Stuffers!
Here we go!
-♪ "Tonight Show" ♪
-♪ Stocking Stuffers ♪
♪ It's the "Tonight Show" ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Every night
until Christmas break,
we're giving away an incredible
gift to every single person
in our studio audience.
You guys excited?
You guys ready for this?
Let's see what
you're taking home tonight.
Questlove, drum roll, please.
[ Drum roll ]
Tonight's Stocking Stuffer is...
a pair of Bose
QuietComfort Earbuds II!
-Yeah, Jimmy,
Bose QuietComfort Earbuds II
weren't designed with
a one-size-fits-all approach.
These next-generation
wireless earbuds
are engineered to fit you.
They personalize
the noise cancelation
and sound performance
to your ears,
so you can enjoy the world's
best noise cancellation
and uninterrupted
immersive listening
wherever you are, Jimmy!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ooh! Look at that!
Whoo!
This is what I'm talking about.
This is the real deal.
I love this.
Oh, it's ready. 100% charged.
Enjoy your gift, everybody.